where'd you learn how to cook or do you
just like follow youtube recipes you're
like i don't follow i just watch a bunch
of cooking things constantly do you like
do you like to watch like what gordon
ramsay video
no
uh i i used to not anymore that was like
tv
jamie oliver
ramsay's more entertainment yeah yeah
yeah yeah educational but nowadays
there's so many different sources
on youtube and i just like food wishes
one thing i've noticed about a lot of
top chefs when they whenever they do
like cooking videos it's like
it's they always add so much [ __ ]
olive oil i don't know i don't know what
it is about [ __ ] olive oil you see a
celebrity chef at olive oil and she's
like just a little touch of olive oil
and they [ __ ] invade italy in the
process i swear to god man
i love the uh
smash cut to an olive field
so it's just just a little dollop of
olive oil one spoon of olive oil
it's like there's like a whole genre of
videos right that is like uh absolutely
[ __ ] god-awful like cocktail recipes
yeah
not not intentional and some of them are
literally just like full bottles of
alcohol like spirits is that the two
shots of vodka it's kind of like that
but taking too far like i was watching a
video and there was this woman telling
you how to make a drink and it was a
cocktail yeah she put like two leaves of
coriander in a bunch of shaved ice and
then she's poured like a whole bottle of
like bacardi right into this thing to
fill it up
and she's like and there you go you have
your and she named the drink it's called
and i was just like what the [ __ ] is
this
this is straight bacardi this isn't a
drink it was like a pint glass as well i
think what the [ __ ] this is this is a
hospital uh booking
what is this
i'm gonna show you some of these [ __ ]
cars
abominations
i didn't mix it with anything
there's no mixer it's just it's just
like some some [ __ ] flowers and [ __ ]
and a whole bottle of jack daniels
that's it
it's terrible essence of the stuff
it's still not a mixer
still not a mixer who's your favorite
youtuber mainly
that's not us
we pay the bills
do you even watch a lot of youtube i do
i watch a lot of food related youtube or
animal related do you watch report of
the week
sometimes
do you like him
do i like do you like his videos
yeah
i don't watch it all the time it's like
once every two months i'm a big fan i
watch every video yeah you watch you
guys watch a lot though i mean
youtubers right that's that's part of
the job
are you a youtuber we are youtuber so
it's i mean it's just part of the job to
watch a lot of youtube and i i don't
know if that's just like warped my
experience because i don't know how much
youtube everyone else watches anymore i
do do you find that because like i
sometimes i talk to someone and i just
now i just assume they are also as verse
with like youtube culture and youtube
videos as i am i i always get reminded
that i'm way too deep into youtube and
memes when i have to when i say a meme
or i reference a meme that is so
in-depth in meme culture that it
requires like knowledge of like seven
previous memes yeah and then knowledge
of each like
variation of said meme yeah that's those
those memes are tough
that's right
that's when i really feel like [ __ ] i'm
really like
because also some memes they are they
are funny if you get it but like when
you try and describe like pee pee poo
poo stinky yeah yeah it's like there's
no way of describing that meme to
someone without showing the video
without also sound like a complete
[ __ ] idiot yeah like i'm glad you
talked to me in like a normal english
level you know what
what you mean
if i was just saying like oh that's
busting mom she'd be like what is
butting i mean i i have that reaction
sometimes of you
i just i think boston is i i'm
i get it dude i feel passionate when i
say
it wouldn't boston right for me to say
like busting
why wouldn't it feel like well because
you're not saying you're with classic
comfortable with it you gotta you gotta
be confident you gotta put some bass
behind it like bursting
[ __ ] out my cheek
tense up before i can even say it right
you're trying to say something
it's busting
so wait who is your favorite youtuber
sorry oh jack japan would be like kim
marguerite cook oh i love him i just
love the way he cuts into the fish
kimono is this like he's pretty big he's
like top 10 japanese youtubers i think
but like he basically just dissects a
shitload of fish oh he that's the thing
this is the guy who killed the frog no
no no that's different that's like the
shock
i remember because like this like
sometimes because melanie gets
recommended so many food videos
sometimes sometimes the weird cooking
videos as well where you have to like
destroy animals
[Music]
i feel like saying preparing the frog
doesn't do it justice it doesn't because
that's not what happened no the guy like
cuts this frog in half and you hear
bones crunching yeah he doesn't prepare
the frog he massacres yeah like robot
walls but like
a man i i feel like i just watched
[ __ ] saw seven yeah you know like
just it's like like we're not gonna put
it up on screen like if you're squeamish
we're not gonna talk about too much
because it's i still think about it and
i'm not like i'm not like a squeamish
person but i felt so bad for the frog
it's a [ __ ] brutal video that was
okay because you know he's going to eat
it yeah
there's nothing wrong with it he's going
to eat it he's not you know it's no more
brutal than killing a cow or something
educational right right i guess it's
just because you don't it's not every
day you see a guy chop a frog in half
yeah to prepare something
because the thing is you never really
think about how animals die before
before they cook they get good i mean
i mean we're so we we're so like we're
like lucky enough to like not have to do
it ourselves a lot of the times that's
what it's like to grow up in a civilized
society right so when i see a full-on
[ __ ]
yeah i mean i mean when i see a [ __ ]
mortal kombat fatality being put on this
frog i'm just like jesus [ __ ] grace
i'm just waiting for like the x-ray zoom
oh yes the hair's getting crushed
i'm sorry very violent yeah yeah i mean
obviously it's a brutal video
pad is
generally not that good yeah that's why
yeah that's why people turn into
vegetarians you know yeah yeah i mean i
like i wouldn't i wouldn't eat anything
that i wasn't prepared to kill myself
yeah that doesn't mean i have to enjoy
the process
i feel like you're a psychopath if you
enjoy putting down an animal to eat yeah
i mean
like it's bad
yeah yeah yeah it came out wrong
no he said that like no i disagree i
like the killing poem
i say if you don't enjoy it what's the
point it came out wrong
oh my god i don't kill i think just
bones crunching just is just generally
unpleasant because even when we were
when we
had to like dissect fish or like cut the
bones just to separate parts of the body
it's it's often quite
yeah does it sound nice i don't enjoy it
when it stops moving it's like when it
feels a little weird
right i think it feels weird yeah i
think it feels weird when it's still
moving yeah yeah that's that's what i
was waiting for struggling yeah yeah
don't say struggle oh god god
oh my god when i buy like live fish i
don't hold it down my husband holds it
down and i
because i can't handle it what are you
saying he's like husband
you put the blood on your hands no
he doesn't want to be the one to poop it
like you know
oh oh you're trying to hold it down
you're
so why can't you hold it down because i
can feel its muscles moving like it's
struggling like you're alive but you
should be prepared for that if you're
going to kill it yeah if you're the one
like excitedly holding the he's going to
eat it too so it's we're sharing the
bread oh wow so when i go to the
restaurant the chef's gonna come out be
like no i'm not gonna lie on it i'm
quite squeamish could you hold down this
this cow while i shoot it
you're just like blaming the you're just
blaming the murder on someone else yeah
you're just trying to pass
like we're in this together
thinking like i don't want to go to hell
if i if i get someone else to do it
it'll be i put the knife okay